[Music]
you want to talk about AI for a second
sure
so I'll just rehash what I told you last
week on the zoom have you looked into it
at all
um no
so in the last two weeks this thing
called Auto GPT was released yes
there's another one called Baby AGI and
now there's a third one
that I forget what it's called but
Auto gbt now is like one of the most
starred repositories on GitHub in a
matter of like two weeks yeah it was
like a pet project from this guy I just
like wanted to see an idea he wanted to
see what it would do yep it's
essentially
taking
multiple different chat GPT instances
and like making them talk to themselves
it's like a recursive chat gbt yeah
where it'll first you basically give it
a goal like you say I want I'm gonna
throw an event in I'm gonna throw like a
whatever an event in a certain place or
I don't know for me I was using it I
wanted like a
a weekly email with like new house songs
that I could like put in a DJ set or
something like that that's what I was
using it for
that's my goal and then it'll generate
it'll tell itself that generate a task
list and then feed the task list back
into gbt and slowly accomplish the tasks
recursively right
so it's essentially and then it's
thinking in between right like it's like
reasoning on how to complete the tasks
what the next next task is yeah and then
feeding itself yeah so it's essentially
a thinking and accomplishing goals and
tasks right
and I got it running on my computer and
I like you know I I basically saw it
writing code
um it's [__]
so cool but really scary
yeah
yeah I watched a video of a dude
remaking
um Flappy Bird with yeah you saw it yeah
yeah it's pretty great apparently
someone made something called chaos GPT
yes that's the other thing I wanted to
bring up
pretty disturbing as like a as like a
you know statement or to experiment I
guess he like publicly released this
thing called chaos gbt which is Auto gbt
with the goal of destroying Humanity
right to see what it would do right now
right and I think it it like
I don't know it didn't get very far I
don't think what this time this time but
like
yeah I don't know like what I don't know
it's like horrifying how fast this stuff
is
yeah I don't know I'm curious to know
how you could have been a bazillionaire
oh yeah
um well
I saw on Twitter
uh it was like a tweet from like some
like TechCrunch like account and it was
like scopely the mobile games company
has been acquired for like 4.2 billion
dollars by
some Saudi Arabian company um and I was
like scopely I recognize that name why
do I recognize that like I really was
like I have experience with this name I
don't know what it is so I went back and
searched my email for scopely and I
found
an email exchange between me and the guy
who led it in 2012. I went and flew to
San Francisco and interviewed there
in 2012 and then sent him this like
really cringy email where I was like
I've spoken with my parents and I think
that or no it was based here and I was
like I think San Francisco is the place
for me
so unfortunately I'm gonna have to like
turn down and he was offering me the
lead
lead game designer role wow
so I would have been a billionaire yeah
lead game designer like yeah I mean
would you ever design I was not
qualified at all I think that's part of
the reason I remember this now I
remember why I said no is because I was
like I'm not [__] cut out I don't
know why this guy thinks I'm cut out for
this but like
I don't know how I've like conned my way
into this situation but like this is
more than imposter syndrome this is like
I am legitimately I will run this
company into the ground because I've
never made a game in my entire life yeah
so good thing you didn't go to scopely
man because then you would not have
fulfilled your destiny as a podcaster I
know exactly
yeah exactly I could have been the lead
of stumble guys yeah yeah I could have
been the inventor of stumble guy stumble
guys dude
oh my God what a rip Strike Force gee
oh it is Marvel sponsored
that's amazing
that's crazy I could have been the brain
the brains behind Dice Buddies
yeah
I mean really dude
you could have been you could have been
driving around La in a McLaren P1 no a
McLaren Senna yeah only 250 or whatever
only 500 of them in the world you would
you could pull up to [__] kazunori
yep with your private security they
[__] stand all around your car they
followed you there and escalate and you
hop out and you walk up to the cause of
nori and then the per the dude working
the [__] Hostess Booth is like yo man
what do you do
pal you heard a dice buddy
that's me ever heard of stumble guys uh
like Fall Guys no no it's different no
it's different no I've never heard of
fall guys before I don't know what that
is it's called stumble guys it's
reinvented it it's a unique game where
friends can participate in various
challenges it's different characters all
racing to the Finish it's several rounds
of games and oh but there's only one
it's such a rip look at this it's a
direct rip that's crazy fun physics play
with friends you heard that AI Drake
song yeah what do you think
it's pretty good it's pretty good right
unfortunately it was pretty good so what
do you think what do you think the
future of like
music and covers is like he's definitely
gonna get sued for that it's on Spotify
right now it's got like 400 500 000
plays already
it got removed
because like on what grounds that it's
not Drake that's his light is no but
it's
it's not his voice it's not like someone
stole something that he already recorded
it's a synthesized voice
yes I think did they call it Drake
though
no he just he uploaded it under his own
artist name which was ghost writer and
it was just like the name of the song
but I think the issue or this goes back
to that like Court ruling where you
can't copyright or like
basically impersonate
yeah but I think you can't he I don't
think he can protect the music as like a
creative
work or something because he can't prove
there was human
um like labor utilized to make it
I think that that's
where like where they could make the
argument like you have to take this down
but also
yeah maybe this is a one of those where
it doesn't matter because like he can
just bury the kid in litigation and it's
like not worth it yeah but it makes me
wonder in a situation where like
umg goes at it with like Sony or some
[__] or like a big Corp goes against
like a big artist and they're like
no yeah they're like no like you [__]
us in the deal and you uh you're trying
to drag this album out so we brought in
writers and uh we we said the contract
said we need to release Five albums by
this day so this album's coming out yeah
yeah that would be some crazy [__] that
would be some crazy [__] like if in the
deal it's like we not only we not only
own the masters of your music but we
also own the license to your voice for
the next five years yeah and we can do
whatever we want with it yep oh dude
posthumous that's [__] crazy
posthumous album rights are gonna go
insane
you're gonna see it bro you're gonna see
it like juice world's family and [__]
like oh my God they're gonna get crazy
offers
it's like sell us your son's likeness
for us to make more music do you think
people
you can't listen to that in the same way
though like you
like his fandom won't be able to turn on
a song like that and be like
because a little part of them is like I
know he was in the studio recording this
and it came from his heart and his brain
definitely but I think what they would
do from then is okay
yes his original audience has like
um actual feelings and empathy but uh
the general population that doesn't
really know who juice world is well
we'll just put it in front of them and
it could also be the same thing as it is
now where with posthumous albums it's
like oh I never knew he recorded that
yes like they could just frame it as
that oh these are just found in the
vault yeah these are on a hard drive
it's a bunch of acapellas he recorded
over other beats that we like took and
produced to be something else you know
but instead it's just synthesized then
he starts making modern references and
you're like what
the [__]
I dropped my iPhone 14 in the toilet
wait what
yeah just like using modern slang yeah